einen Hammer das ist alles was Jascha
dabei hat der Vermessungsingenieur ist
für die türkischen Behörden in adiaman
unterwegs untersucht welches der
beschädigten Häuser in der Stadt
einsturzgefährdet ist
[Musik]
überall auf der Welt macht man das so
mit einem Hammer und dann schauen wir
nach das ist eine internationale
anerkannte Methode eine andere gibt es
nicht
wenn die Häuser selbst darf er nicht
rein deshalb sucht davon außen nach
rissen den tragenden Säulen wenn er die
findet wird das Gebäude abgerissen
erzählt er uns seine Arbeit ist
gefährlich auch wegen der vielen
Nachbeben
was soll ich tun wir müssen die Gefahr
auf uns nehmen für unser Volk es ist
unsere Pflicht dieses Opfer zu bringen
er ist mit uns
blühender Fan von Präsident Erdogan
erzählt er uns die türkische Regierung
mache alles richtig in dieser
Katastrophe viele Anwohner sehen das
anders auch wenn längst nicht alle sich
trauen ihre Meinung so offen zu äußern
wie Mädchen
ich werde die Wahrheit sagen die
Behörden haben uns nicht unterstützt zu
diesem Hotel kamen erst am vierten Tag
Rettungsteams ihr Bürger haben mit
eigenen Mitteln die Rettungsarbeiten
durchgeführt es kam niemand vom
Katastrophenschutz kein roter Halbmond
mein Verwandter war unter den Trümmern
ich habe den Bagger geholt und ihn
selbst rausgeholt
das Zentrum von adiaman ist
weitestgehend zerstört 600.000 Einwohner
hatte die Stadt mal jetzt sind drei
Viertel der Häuser eingestürzt oder
müssen abgerissen werden eine riesige
Staubwolke liegt über der Stadt die
Aufräumarbeiten werden wohl noch Monate
dauern
die Überlebenden von adiaman sind in
Zelten untergebracht überall in der
Stadt auf jeder Freifläche die sicher
ist die großen internationalen
Hilfsorganisationen sind schon wieder
weg auch weil der türkische Staat immer
wieder betont alles im Griff zu haben
davon wollen wir uns am Fußballstadion
selbst ein Bild machen
hier gibt es eine staatliche
Anlaufstelle Hilfsgüter Essen werden
verteilt Zeltplätze vergeben
auch mehr als drei Wochen nach dem Beben
ist der Bedarf an Hilfe riesig sagen uns
Überlebende
straffe ich gleich da wir brauchen
Kleidung wir können uns mit
Lebensmitteln versorgen aber wir haben
Probleme in anderen Bereichen wir
brauchen Wasser wir leben in Zelten es
wäre gut wenn es ein Waschbecken und
eine Toilette geben würde
plötzlich tauchen Sicherheitsbeamte auf
wir müssen das Interview beenden und
unsere Akkreditierung vorzeigen
wenn internationale Journalisten über
diese Katastrophe hier in der Türkei
berichten
wir machen nichts Falsches nichts
Falsches gegen euch übersetzt das
im Erdbebengebiet hat die Regierung den
Ausnahmezustand verhängt Macht
demonstrieren einschüchtern war bleiben
so läuft das hier
warum haben sie uns das nicht sagen
[Musik]
warum ich das nicht sagen kann ich bin
Beamter
der Mann könnte von einer Sondereinheit
sein wir müssen ihn verpixeln wer
Sicherheitsbeamte offen zeigt muss mit
harten Konsequenzen rechnen
[Musik]
unsere Anfragen mit Verantwortlichen zu
sprechen laufen ins Lehre dabei sitzen
sie alle im gouverneurs-palast von adia
Mann wegen der Katastrophe arbeitet auch
der türkische Infrastrukturminister
gerade von hier das Chaos aus Rettern
und Helfern haben er und die anderen
gleich vor der Haustür
die Kritik wird lauter zum Beispiel bei
den Kurden die in adia man die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung bilden in einem
Versammlungshaus koordinieren
freiwillige Hilfe für die Erdbebenopfer
auch Abgeordnete der Oppositionspartei
HDP sind vor Ort sowie Philipp nass und
ja sie ist in Deutschland geboren wirft
im türkischen Staat vor Hilfe aktiv zu
behindern
formuliermann mit dem Hirn erwähnen aber
hier haben wir ja das nicht mal die
Zelte reingelassen worden sind Essen
wurde nicht reingelassen es wurde alles
beschlagnahmt er läuft alles über das
afad oder
Katastrophenschutz oder wir lassen uns
niemanden rein zu zögerlich zu wenig zu
spät glauben viele hier habe der
türkische Staat auf diese jahrhundert
Katastrophe reagiert von einer Bankrott
Erklärung spricht Ömer der galliolu auch
erst HDP Abgeordneter gegen die Partei
läuft gerade ein Verbotsverfahren er
glaubt sogar dass die AKP von Präsident
Erdogan das Erdbeben nutzen könnte um
die geplanten Wahlen im Mai zu
manipulieren
die Frage der Durchführung von Wahlen
ist in der Tat umstritten denn die
Bevölkerung von adiaman nimmt ab viele
Menschen verlassen dass Erdbebengebiet
deshalb könnte es bei den Wahlen zu
einer Täuschung kommen denn die
erdbebenprovinzen sind leer
der Vermessungsingenieur will mit uns
nicht weiter über Politik reden aber
auch er spricht vom Schmerz der Opfer
der Wunde für sein Land die Heilung
brauche
wir wünschen der Türkei dass sie zur
Ruhe kommt wir wünschen Gesundheit
Schönheit Frieden und Brüderlichkeit
hier in adiamanten und den
Nachbarprovinzen wird Brüderlichkeit ja
gerade vorgelebt möge Allah unser Land
vor Katastrophen und Unruhen schützen
Gesundheit Frieden Brüderlichkeit
große Worte in adiaman wo die Menschen
nur mit einem beschäftigt sind
überleben weitermachen irgendwie
[Musik]